-On the eve of the
midterm elections,
the Republican Party has made
their agenda crystal clear.
If they regain power,
they will once again
thrust our government into chaos
while subverting
future elections
to cement permanent
Republican rule.
And they've also made clear
that Donald Trump is still
and will remain
the leader of their party
and that they will march
in lockstep behind him
if they win on Tuesday.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Theme music plays ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
If you watch Republican
midterm ads
or listen to Republicans talk,
they pretend that they're
focused on issues like crime
or gas prices or inflation.
Dr. Mehmet Oz, the GOP candidate
for Senate in Pennsylvania,
tried to highlight gas prices
by posting this incredibly
bizarre picture of himself
standing under a sign
showing gas prices
at a Sheetz convenience store
on the side of the road
in Altoona,
just hanging out
under a gas station sign,
you know, like
ordinary Americans do.
So stoic, too.
He looks like a car dealership
tube man after he quit caffeine.
There are actually
a few more things
I want to zoom in on,
in this picture,
as part of our new segment,
"An Even Closer Look."
[ Theme music plays ]
Alright, first of all,
why are his arms crossed
like he's doing a pose in the
opening credits of "Shark Tank"?
"So, you want to sell pills
that don't do anything?
I'm intrigued."
[ Laughter ]
Also, I love his serious face.
Look at him.
He's a gas station bouncer.
"Sir, you're not on the list.
Get your beef jerky elsewhere.
Ladies, right this way."
And I'm sorry, there's only one
Pennsylvania Senate candidate
who can pull off
the nightclub bouncer look.
I mean, that's a guy
who will not be fooled
by your out-of-state I.D.
Plus, Fetterman is so tall that
when he takes the same picture,
gas looks like
it's only $0.99.
[ Laughter ]
And finally,
let's zoom in Oz' feet.
Why is he standing
on a tiny rock?
Does he think
he's stranded at sea?
Is he playing
"the floor is lava"?
Or more likely, is he wearing
super expensive shoes?
"I stand for all Pennsylvanians
on a tiny rock
so I don't get dirt
on my Brunello Cucinellis."
This has been
"An Even Closer Look."
[ Theme music plays ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
So, Republicans claim
they're focused on issues.
"Oh, but Seth," you might say,
"didn't you just spend 2 minutes
making fun
of a picture of Dr. Oz?"
Yes, but I never claim
to be focused on the issues.
Republicans did.
And when you press them
for specifics
on what they would actually do
if they win,
they don't really have any.
That's what happened
when Florida Senator Rick Scott,
who's in charge of taking
back the Senate
for Republicans this year,
went on "Meet the Press"
and was asked if he could name
a bill Republicans would pass
that President Biden
might actually sign into law.
And instead, he just repeated
a bunch of
lazy Republican slogans.
-Alright, let's assume
you've got the majority.
I'm gonna take you
at your word.
You're gonna get the House.
You're gonna get the Senate.
What's the first bill
a Republican Congress
sends to
the president's desk
that you actually think
he would sign?
[ Light laughter ]
-I think the issues --
we've got to deal
with inflation.
So we've got to figure out
how to spend our money wisely
so we don't continue
this inflation.
I think we've got to do
whatever we can
to get this crime rate down.
So I think we have
to look at that.
We've got to secure the border.
So I think those are the things
that we have to focus on.
-Yeah, but
none of those are bills.
We can all name issues.
You know, we're asking
for solutions.
When you go to the doctor,
he doesn't just point out
a bunch of [Bleep] that's wrong
with you and leave.
"Well, we've got to do something
about the gallbladder,
and that heart's no good.
Plus, a bunch of your bones
are out of place,
and you need a new kidney.
Anyway, good luck
with all of that.
I'm gonna go hang out under
the sign at the gas station
with the other 'doctors.'"
So, once again,
Republicans are making promises
they obviously have
no intention of keeping.
How many times do we have to go
through this dance with the GOP
before we learn
that they're lying?
Remember when they did
the same thing with Obamacare?
For almost an entire decade,
they said
Obamacare had to be repealed,
that it was
their number-one priority,
and that they had a solution
that would be so much better
and cost so much less and
give everyone great healthcare?
Remember when
Trump said all this?
-We are coming up with something
that I believe
will be very good.
A bill that's going to be
a phenomenal bill.
We're going to have something
that's going to be
much more understood
and much more popular
than people can even imagine.
This will be a plan where
you can choose your doctor.
This will be a plan
where you can choose your plan.
And you know what the plan is?
This is the plan.
This is a great bill.
There's a great plan.
And this will be
great healthcare.
You're going to have
such great healthcare
at a tiny fraction of the cost,
and it's gonna be so easy.
-As usual, with Trump,
he couldn't stop overpromising.
It's one thing to lie and say
you have a plan when you don't.
It's another to say that
nonexistent plan you don't have
is the greatest plan
to ever exist
in the history of civilization.
"This plan is so amazing.
You're gonna get everything --
perfect healthcare,
completely free.
And if you like your doctor,
you can keep your doctor.
You can keep him
in your basement,
chained to a wall."
And they'll be there 24/7
to serve your medical needs.
The doctors don't like it,
but you're gonna love it.
You're gonna love it."
Also, remember when he said
it would be so easy?
Like he was a dude trying
to impress a date at a carnival.
"Hey, babe,
you want that giant bear?
No problem.
Gonna be so easy.
I can hit that clown's mouth
in one shot.
[Bleep]
[ Laughter ]
Not even close! Damn it!
The clown moved!
I swear, the clown moved, babe!
No! No!
I won't let it go!
You don't understand!
I'm gonna go to the Sheetz
and hang out under the sign!"
[ Laughter ]
Now, that's two.
That's two callbacks
to the Sheetz sign.
So, if you know
anything about comedy,
there's probably --
probably one more coming.
[ Laughter ]
You're not out of the woods yet,
"Dr. Oz."
[ Laughter ]
Anyway, Trump
was, of course, lying,
just like the rest
of the Republican Party,
when it came time
to actually pass a bill
to replace Obamacare
after nearly a decade.
I'm realizing now it was a gun,
and I threw a ball.
Right?
[ Laughter ]
Mm-hmm. It just dawned on me.
I'm mime-throwing,
and it's gonna be
a tricky edit.
[ Laughter ]
When it came time to actually
pass a bill to replace Obamacare
after nearly a decade
of empty promises,
they freaked out like a
hung-over college freshman
waking up in his dorm room
at 6:00 a.m.
with a blank piece of paper
stuck to his face.
"Oh, [Bleep]!
Oh, this is due in an hour!
Oh, let's see.
What do I have so far?
'This will be a thesis where
you can choose your thesis.
and you know what the thesis is,
this is the thesis.'
Ohh, aw!"
[ Cheers and applause ]
The same thing is playing out
all over again.
Except this time,
all the lies and empty promises
are concealing something
much more nefarious.
And that is the real reason
Republicans want power,
so they can rig future elections
and install permanent
one-party rule.
And that's not
just me saying that.
Republicans are saying that.
They are saying it in public,
out in the open,
for everyone to hear.
The GOP candidate
for governor in Wisconsin,
Tim Michels,
who is in a dead heat
with the Democratic incumbent,
Tony Evers,
said at a campaign stop
last week,
"Republicans will never lose
another election in Wisconsin
after I'm elected governor."
That wasn't even
a secret confession
caught on hidden camera
at a private event.
He said that at
a public campaign stop.
It used to be that
when you caught politicians
confessing
to something scandalous,
it would be on grainy
black-and-white footage
from a motel security camera.
Now they just yell it
into a microphone
like Michael Buffer
before a boxing match.
"Let's get ready for fascism!"
[ Up-tempo music plays ]
By the way, not the real song.
It's a fake sound, like
we couldn't afford the real one,
thanks to inflation.
[ Laughter ]
Anyway, the point is,
the thing that really
motivates Republicans
is not the cost of living
or gas prices
or any of that stuff.
It's election denialism.
Trump's big lie
about the 2020 election
is now the beating heart
of conservative ideology.
It's their single
obsessive focus
and the thing
that galvanizes them,
as you can see from a rally
Trump held in Miami last night
for Florida Senator Marco Rubio,
where the crowd
actually chanted with Trump
when he claimed
the 2020 election was stolen.
And by the way,
just for the record,
what you're about
to hear from Trump,
as if you even needed
to hear me say this,
is complete and utter nonsense.
Just this week, the Pennsylvania
Supreme Court ruled, in effect,
that I was 100% right,
and the 2020 presidential
election in Pennsylvania
was riddled with ballots
that should never
have been counted.
Far more
than necessary to win.
They stated that big things
that took place
in 2020
presidential election
in Pennsylvania
were not allowed.
They weren't allowed to do it.
Now, they did it anyway.
But they weren't allowed.
But they refused the court
to invalidate the election.
Instead, in the future,
they say.
[ Chuckles ]
That's true. That's true.
By a lot.
-You know...
[ Laughter ]
You know how when
you read Supreme Court opinions,
they always use language
like, "Big things took place
that were not allowed."
[ Laughter ]
You can read all about it
in Trump v.
Bad Guys, Nasty Guys.
But that's what really gets
Republicans going, not --
You can notice,
they're not chanting,
"Solve inflation
or balance the budget."
Also in general, whenever an
angry mob is chanting something,
you want a politician
who will try to calm them down,
not respond by saying,
"That's true."
When the townsfolk
showed up with torches
and pitchforks
to kill Frankenstein,
Trump probably
would have been there saying,
"You know what?
You guys are right.
We have to kill
that giant green monster.
We got to kill him
with the bolts in his neck.
Personally, I've always been
more of a Dracula fan.
We love Dracula, don't we?
We love Dracula.
I met him during a presidential
visit to Transylvania.
I was there.
He came up to me.
a big guy, tough guy,
tears pouring up his face,
because he was hanging
by his feet like a bat.
So the tears were dripping
from his eyes,
down his forehead,
onto the floor.
It was very special.
He said to me, 'Mr. Trump, sir,
I want to suck your blood.'
And I said, 'Dracula,
you remind me of my son.'"
Although...
[ Laughter ]
...my favorite crowd chant
during that rally
came when Trump was ranting
about his first impeachment --
the one where he tried
to extort Ukraine
to help him cheat
in the 2020 election.
And he attacked one of
the lead impeachment managers,
Congressman Adam Schiff.
-So, the speech he made
was total you-know-what.
I won't use it, because
my wife always says --
she always says, "Darling,
don't use the word
'bull[Bleep].'"
So I'm not gonna use it.
I'm telling you -- first lady.
"'[Bleep]' --
Don't use that word."
Wow, you guys are the coolest
kids in fifth grade.
[ Laughter ]
"We got a substitute teacher
today.
Let's all chant '[Bleep]'
and see if he cries."
[ Laughter ]
But Trump remains obsessed
with the election
and with his two impeachments,
which is why
Republicans have made it clear
that one of the first things
they'll do if they
get back in power
is use Congress to investigate
their political enemies,
impeach various
Cabinet officials,
like Merrick Garland,
prosecute Dr. Anthony Fauci,
and even impeach Biden himself,
which has led
former President Barack Obama
to add a little comedy routine
to his stump speech
about how ridiculous that is.
-They're on record.
If they get control of Congress,
they will spend
the next two years
investigating President Biden
and their political opponents.
That's all they want to do.
They see it as payback.
Some of them have said
they're going to impeach
President Biden.
Now, they're not sure why.
[ Laughter ]
They're not sure what for yet.
But, apparently,
that's beside the point.
-You know, we've said it before
and we'll say it again.
One of the only good things
about campaign season
is the return
of stand-up comedy Obama.
"Let's see.
What else? What else?
You see that photo of Dr. Oz?
What's up with this weird dude?
Standing on the side of the road
like a restaurant mascot.
I said to Michelle -- I said,
'I didn't know
they had a Bob's Little Boy.
[ Laughter ]
This ain't New Jersey.
You got to pump your own gas.
Dried-up,
Spock-looking mother[Bleep]."
[ Laughter ]
And there's it.
That's the third.
That's it.
[ Laughter ]
Anyway, that's what Republicans
are gonna do.
They're gonna use the levers
of political -- of power
for political retribution
and to plunge our government
and our economy into crisis
after crisis after crisis.
Again, this isn't a weird
conspiracy theory I made up.
This is all just stuff they've
said themselves in public.
They want to impeach Biden
and his cabinet,
investigated Fauci,
pass a national abortion ban,
hold the debt ceiling hostage
to force cuts to
Social Security and Medicare,
which among other things,
could potentially
detonate our economy.
That's all stuff
they've said on the record.
It will be the Trump era
over and over again.
Nonstop crisis,
Nonstop chaos, nonstop...
But most important of all,
they want to use their positions
in key states across the country
to rig future elections
and cement one-party
Republican rule.
The GOP candidate for
secretary of state in Nevada,
Jim Marchant, who openly said
he and other pro-Trump
secretaries of state
around the country
will make sure
that Trump wins,
no matter what, in 2024.
-We have something in common.
President Trump and I
lost an election in 2020
because of a rigged election.
[ Crowd cheers ]
And when I'm secretary of state
of Nevada,
we're gonna fix it.
And when my coalition
of secretary of state candidates
around the country
get elected,
we're gonna fix
the whole country,
and President Trump is gonna be
president again in 2024.
-Once again, they're just
admitting their plans
to steal
the 2024 election in advance.
Seriously, what else
do we have to do
to get people
to pay attention to this?
Do I have to stand on
a street corner in Times Square,
dressed like Abe Lincoln,
handing out pamphlets
like one of those guys
advertising
a Presidents' Day sale?
Because I will do it.
Actually, I won't do it,
but I will make Wally do it.
-[ Clears throat ]
Four score and seven
cue cards -- Oh.
[ Laughter ]
-God.
It's like...
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's like a dead heat
with Daniel Day-Lewis.
[ Laughter ]
It's very possible the Democrats
will lose seats tomorrow,
since historically
that always is what happens
to the party in power.
In fact, it would be very normal
and maybe even unremarkable
if it weren't for the fact
that Republicans want
to subvert the system
to ensure that they
never lose power again.
That's their plan.
And we know that's their plan
because they've said
that's their plan.
It's a plan...
-Where you can choose your plan.
And you know what the plan is?
This is the plan.
-This has been "A Closer Look."
[ Theme music plays ]
The midterm elections
are coming up.
So to make sure that you're
good to vote in this election,
visit our good friends
at headcount.org
to check your
voter-registration status
or to register to vote.